à partir du 21 décembre sur city
génération et du bio
j'ai décidé de me présenter pour être
candidate à la mer
attardez vous avez un serial killer dans
ce village mais moi j'ai toujours rêvé
d'une affaire comme ça je suis candidat
à la mairie
je suis québécoise
c'est ma meuf france québec
c'est une claque aux échanges
interculturels une immersion chez nos
cousins québécois seulement pour le
meilleur du pire auquel très bien tu
caps à une production aussi signature
france-québec saison 2 à partir du 21
décembre inédit sur city
à la demande l'intégralité de la saison
2 en exclusivité dès la diffusion du
premier épisode sur 16 go
pour une piqûre de rappel retrouvez
également à la demande l'intégralité de
la saison 1 de france québec sur procès
s beau